-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for watching.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, former president
Trump is in the news.
Apparently he's been trashing
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
behind his back, calling him
a dull guy who has no chance of
beating him in a potential
2024 matchup.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "I have to
insult him behind his back
'cause I can't tweet it
to his face."
[ Laughter ]
I feel like Trump is slipping.
A few years ago he would have
had like 10 nicknames
for this guy by now.
It's like, "Ron Dull-Santis."
[ Laughter ]
I think the insults backfired
'cause just hearing Trump's name
jump-started Biden's approval
rating back up in the 50s.
[ Laughter ]
It's in the 50s now. Yeah.
I think this is
actually a nice change
'cause usually when two Florida
guys get into a fight,
they're drunk and shirtless.
[ Laughter ]
But DeSantis doesn't seem fazed.
He said that he's going to
handle the insult
just like COVID
and completely ignore it.
[ Laughter ]
And speaking of
the former president,
this weekend he held
his first rally of the year.
Let's take a listen to
what he had to say.
-The grocery shelves, the
department store shelves,
they're empty.
You had an excuse not to buy
Christmas gifts.
You say to your loved one,
"Darling, I'm sorry.
I love you very much,
but I just can't.
There's no merchandise
in Tiffany.
I wanted to buy you
the most beautiful ring,
but they don't have any rings
anymore.
Nobody has anything."
We never even heard the term
"supply change."
[ Laughter ]
-Supply change.
Well, a year off,
and he's still got it.
I think he's still got it.
I think...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think he's still got it.
He's right. He's right.
He's right.
We've never heard the term
"supply change."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then he started talking
about things
being expensive
'cause of inflammation.
[ Laughter ]
Trump knows exactly what
concerns working families --
the ring inventory at Tiffany's.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, as if we're not
dealing with enough right now,
doctors are warning people
against a new TikTok trend
called "sleepy chicken,"
where people cook chicken
in NyQuil.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-No.
-Yeah.
-What?
-There's actually another name
for chicken
that makes you sleepy.
It's called turkey.
[ Laughter ]
Just eat turkey.
That's right.
Doctors are warning people
against cooking chicken
in cold medicine.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, the recipe is wild.
Take a look at this recipe.
It says add oil to pan
then add chicken.
Then sauté in bottle of NyQuil.
[ Laughter ]
After that,
cook chicken through,
transfer to plate,
and then enjoy.
After that, wake up facedown
in plate four hours later.
[ Laughter ]
Next, stumble into garage,
drive car straight through
garage door.
Then drive to Taco Bell
on wrong side of road
going three miles per hour.
After that, remove shirt, demand
eggplant parm and a Twinkie.
Then get arrested.
[ Laughter ]
Next, use one phone call on
the only number you remember --
the house you grew up
in as a kid.
[ Laughter ]
Then spend night in jail,
join gang for protection.
After that, get neck tattoo of
prison nickname --
"Sizzurp Chicken."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then gain freedom but lose job
as high school principal.
And finally,
refrigerate leftovers.
So, I mean,
it's a tricky recipe.
Just stay away from it.
[ Applause ]
Hey, did you guys see this?
A Norwegian cruise ship canceled
its trip
mid-voyage due to COVID.
[ Laughter ]
And now a bunch of passengers
are stuck at sea.
Norwegian told the passengers,
"There's no reason to panic.
There's plenty of NyQuil chicken
for everyone."
[ Laughter ]
Passengers are furious.
They're like,
"When I booked this cruise
during a COVID surge,
who knew this could happen?"
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's just stranded
and angry.
That's got to be
a lot of pressure
for the cruise ship comic.
"So, where are you folks
being held from?"
[ Laughter ]
I saw that over the weekend
on the Saturday edition
of the "Today" show,
one meteorologist had a cough
coming on, and she did her best
to fight through it.
Just watch this.
-Well, our friends out west have
lucked out with dry conditions
and mild conditions out towards
the Rockies.
And, of course, we're seeing...
that winter storm
that's going to impact
the East Coast.
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at your...forecast.
[ Laughter ]
-Somara getting
a little bit of water,
and she will be back with
more in just a bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, poor thing.
[ Laughter ]
-She sounds like the captain of
a Norwegian cruise.
[ Laughter ]
At first it looked like she was
just overcome with the emotion
at the sight of a cold front.
And then "I -- I promised myself
I wouldn't do this."
[ Laughter ]
Could we just watch that again
just 'cause it's funny?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, we're seeing...
that winter storm
that's going to impact
the East Coast.
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at your...forecast.
[ Laughter ]
-Some business news --
I saw that once again
Netflix increased its monthly
subscription prices.
[ Audience booing ]
Apparently Netflix's plan is
to take so much of our money
that we'll have to enter
a real-life squid game.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix says that you can
either pay the increase
or enjoy not knowing
what anyone's talking about
for the next 70 years.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I heard that
there's a new push here
in New York City to put
trash containers on the streets
so that there aren't
giant mountains
of trash bags on the sidewalks.
It's like a developer came
in and said, "I got it --
rat condominiums."
[ Laughter ]
It should be great.
This way, instead of having to
look at ugly piles of trash,
we'll get to see all
these beautiful dumpsters.